when the power's out at home the family
car suddenly becomes a useful extension
a place to heat up and charge up
this couple have been without
electricity for almost two days
following Russian drone strikes against
Ukraine's energy supplies
despite the discomfort there's a spirit
of defiance at this residential Block in
Odessa even as the threat of more
blackouts looms this winter is
by turning out the lights across the
country with targeted strikes Vladimir
Putin seems to want to break that will
his strategy has turned people's homes
into a different kind of Front Line
Iranian suicide drones have played a key
part in moscow's ability to attack
Ukraine's energy infrastructure causing
blackouts like the one here
those drone attacks largely stopped
towards the end of last month as the
stockpiles ran out but they've started
up again and the UK has said it's likely
that Russia has received a resupply from
Tehran
fighting back Ukraine has set up places
called points of invincibility where
people can plug in
this family are learning new tricks to
survive in the Darkness
we are here in warmless in them with a
tea hot tea and with
um
recharging yes our gadgets oh thanks for
it so we even try to play cards at home
with the candles
lights were on again in the center of
the city as Engineers battled to
reconnect the Grid in this alternative
war of attrition
debraham Sky News Odessa